all right turning now to a very
difficult story that we're reporting on
tens of millions of americans
are unemployed because of the
coronavirus crisis
and many people are also dealing with
another huge challenge
soaring food prices the non-profit
feeding america has a network of 200
food banks and
60 000 food programs across the country
they estimate more than 54.3 million
people
may face hunger because of the pandemic
this year
including 18 million children only on
cbs this morning feeding america ceo
claire babino fontenot
joins us now from dallas to talk about
this good morning to you claire
good morning thank you so much for
having me
so can you describe for our audience uh
you've said that your organization has
never
seen anything like this describe what
it's like right now
on the front lines yes
so as you said we've never seen anything
not quite like this we've seen a
significant increase in need
and some decrease in supply from some of
our traditional sources
and all in the middle of a global health
pandemic so
we've had to put in place new protocols
to keep the people who
need us and the people who are providing
those services to them safe
so it's it's simply unprecedented these
times
we just recently engaged in a really
extensive research with mckinsey and
what we were able to discover
unfortunately is that over the course of
the next 12 months
our estimate is that there's going to be
a
17 billion pound meal
need that our remarkable network
um of those 200 food banks 60 000 agency
partners around the country
with the help and interventions we've
already received we believe we can fill
about
seven billion pounds of that need that
leaves a 10 billion pound gap
that translates into about 8 billion
meals that people out there over the
course of the next 12 months gonna need
and as you also highlighted so many of
them are going to be children and there
are some other really vulnerable
communities
that are being inordinately impacted as
well so the need is great and this has
to be an all-in fight so i'm so glad
you're having me to talk about it
well you know i think a lot of americans
like myself would be astounded
to know that this is happening in the
united states in 2020
the richest most powerful country in the
world you mentioned some of the people
who would most
be impacted by this describe others
besides the children of course who are
going to be severely impacted by
all this yeah if you'll indulge me i'll
talk about the kids for one more moment
um so first ordinarily without a
pandemic there are about 22 million kids
around the country who rely on free and
reduced lunches
for many of those children the only
consistent access to
a nutritious meal that they get is at
school so while we
try to figure out how to get kids back
to school safely
there are children out there who are
hungry right now and who need help
two other communities that are
inordinately impacted are communities of
color
not only are communities of color about
two times more likely to be
food insecure they're also two times
more likely to suffer from some of the
key
chronic illnesses that make covet 19
more lethal
so they're dealing with so many issues
right now making an already vulnerable
community
even more vulnerable and then rural
america this is an area that is not
often talked about
that i want to make certain that that
your audience is aware of as well
of the communities around the country
over 80 percent of the most
food insecure counties in this country
are in rural america
so the need is great it's deep it cuts
across
all types of demographics across this
country there's a lot of need and i
think that we're well positioned to help
people right now when they need them
when they need us the most and i hope
that we will
claire i recently had an opportunity to
speak to a grassroots organization
that is stocking sidewalk refrigerators
with free food and they're also helping
the community to become self-sustainable
what programs are
you working with to ensure that because
it's one thing to provide those meals
it's another
for these communities to be able to
actually feed themselves
you're absolutely right i will not nor
will my network be satisfied
to feed an increasingly growing line we
must do some things to address some of
the systemic needs that give rise to the
line
we want the line to shrink we want to do
a great job
with the people who come to us for help
we don't need them to help us
to need us in the way that they do now
so a lot of the work that we do
is around interventions we refer to it
as our empower work
it's work programmatic design that we do
going into communities
and helping communities to have
microphones to speak for themselves
asking them what do they need meeting
them where they are and helping them to
move forward
that's a lot of the work that we do at
feeding america
during this covet crisis one of the
benefits i believe of of investing in
the work of feeding america
is that we have a national lens that we
can apply and we ask our food banks and
our agencies around the country
to assess and give us estimates of where
the most acute needs are
and then through the gifting that we're
able to provide or grants that we're
able to provide through
through donations that we receive we're
able to go right where the need
is so we've made inordinate investments
in each of these three communities that
are so fragile right now
so that's uh hopefully we can continue
to do that work with additional
investments
from you see behind me
feedingamerica.org
that's a great way for your audience to
help with this effort
by going through feedingamerica.org and
making any type of donation donation
that they can
we will then reinvest them in the
community they can also use that website
to find a food bank
near them food banks are spread out
across this country
and they're there inside of those
communities helping people
on the ground i've had the great
privilege during this pandemic of going
out
and seeing the need and witnessing i've
been out there on the front lines with
many of our members
and they're really stepping up to this
challenge i think they should be
commended but as i said they definitely
need help so right now
we're encouraging congress and we ask
your audience to also encourage congress
to get back to that negotiating table
and to look at some federal
interventions that can do some things
that we can't
yes well the work that you are doing uh
claire is so very important so very
vital
uh to the citizens of this country and
we thank you for it and as you say
people can go to feedingamerica.org for
more information uh claire thank you so
much we appreciate it